THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA
ATKINS BATES BACKER BOARD JUST
BRADFORD CABALLERO PROTESTING
DALLY DODD THE RAZA EGGMAN
GLAZER GONZALEZ GROSS HERTZBERG
HUESO HER TADO JONES KAMLAGER
LAYERED. LEYVA MCGUIRE MELENDEZ
MEN NEWMAN NIELSEN A TRAIL OF
BOTH PAN PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO
INNER AMBERG BY CASKEY WIENER
WILK. SENATORS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUEST BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY SENATOR DR SO
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WE WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG BY SENATOR MELINDA IS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. A LITTLE
CHILD CARRIED WATER IN A
BATTERED TEN PANNIER AND
ALTHOUGH IT WAS AT THAT TIME A
TASK SHE ONLY HALF UNDERSTOOD
ALL HER LIFE SHE WOULD BECOME A
BEARER OF LIFE A BRINGER OF THE
WATER THAT CLEANSES AND FLAKES
PURIFIES AND SOUP IS. A LIQUID
THAT SPEAKS NOT OF ITSELF BUT
PROCLAIMS ITS SOURCE THE GENIUS
OF ITS MAKER. THE MEMORY OF
THAT LITTLE CHILD FIX IN THAT
DEFINING AMBIVALENT MOMENT.
SHOWS THAT WOULD CARRY THE
WATER MIGHT NOT INDEED BE FINE-
FIT. BUT WHAT MATTERS FIRST AND
FINALLY IS THE WATER ITSELF.
UNSULLIED AND MIRACULOUS. THIS
IS TAKEN FROM MERRY WHITMAN THE
WATER CARRIER. GRACIOUS AND
MERCIFUL GOD. ON THIS WORLD
WATER DAY WE RECALL THAT YOUR
SPIRIT MOVED OVER THE WATERS OF
CREATION OUR BODIES ARE AT
LEAST 60% WATER WE DEPEND ON
WATER FOR LIFE WE PRAY FOR
HUMILITY TO SEE ALL THE WAYS WE
TAKE WATER FOR GRANTED. SEND
YOUR SPIRIT TO HELP US
CONFRONT. THOSE WHO USE WATER
TO CREATE STRIFE AND CONFLICT.
HAVE MERCY ON THOSE WHO ARE
SICK OR IN NEED BECAUSE THEY
CANNOT ACCESS SAFE WATER. WE'RE
THANKFUL FOR YOUR GIFT TO WATER
SCENE IN THE BEAUTY OF
WATERFALLS PLACID LAKES RIVERS
AND OCEANS FULL OF AMAZING
CREATURES. GIVE US GUIDANCE ON
HOW TO BE BETTER STEWARDS OF
THIS FINITE RESOURCE WE ASK ALL
OF THIS IN YOUR NAME I'M IN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THE FLAG SALUTE I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
WHICH IS- HE- YES. MEMBERS
TODAY WE HAVE SENATORS LIMóN
AND STERN PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY GOOD AFTERNOON AND
WELCOME TO YOU ADDITIONALLY I
WOULD LIKE TO ANNOUNCE THAT
SENATOR DRAWS A SOLID
CELEBRATED A BIRTHDAY BIRTHDAY
OVER THE WEEKEND HAPPY
BIRTHDAY. HI. AND I'D ALSO LIKE
TO ANNOUNCE THAT SENATOR
MCGUIRE AND HIS WIFE ERICA
MCGUIRE CELEBRATE THE BIRTH OF
THEIR SON CONNOR MICHAEL
MCGUIRE WEIGHING IN AT EIGHT
POUNDS TEN DOWNTOWN SAYS. A
GREAT CONGRATULATIONS TO THEM.
I DO HAVE TO SAY THAT HE WAS
COMPLAINING THAT THE BABY
DIDN'T GET A- LACK OF SLEEP
DURING DURING THE NIGHT AND I'M
NOT SURPRISED AT ALL. MEMBERS.
CAN ASK FOR SOME ATTENTION SO
WE CAN GET MOVING TODAY
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. UNDER MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR MARCH FIFTEENTH
THROUGH THE EIGHTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WILL BE APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
THE CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE. SECOND UNDER THE SECOND
READING FILE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL TWO
TWENTY ONE WITH AMENDMENTS
THREE SIXTY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL TEN WITH
AMENDMENTS THREE FORTY FOUR
WITH AMENDMENTS AND SENATE BILL
THREE NINETY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MOVING ON TO A GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS ITEM NUMBER SIX
CENTER HERTZBERG. MADAM
PRESIDENT. GOOD MORNING AND I'M
HERE TO ASK FOR THE SUPPORT OF
THIS ISSUE AUGUST BODY IN THE
CONFIRMATION OF DOCTOR OSYTH
MAHMOUD FOR THE APPOINTMENT TO
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD DR
MAHMOUD IS A PRACTICING
PHYSICIAN FOR INTERNAL MEDICINE
AND PULMONARY DISEASE AT
HUNTINGTON MEMORIAL HOSPITAL.
IN PASADENA HE WAS APPROVED
AFTER A LONG HEARING BY THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON
FEBRUARY THREE. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
THURMOND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES HI BAKER AYE FORGES
AYE BRADFORD HI CUT BY A FIVE
COURTESY AYE DALLY. HI DODD
FIVE THE RAZA HI EGGMAN HI
GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ I GROWTH HI
HERTZBERG. HI HUESO HI HER TADO
I JONES FIVE KAMLAGER. HI
LAYERED I LEYVA. FIVE WIRE.
MELENDEZ I MEN HI NEWMAN FIVE
NIELSEN HI A CHILL OF BOTH.
FIVE PAN AYE PORTANTINO. ROTH
FIVE RUBIO. HI SKINNER. HI
NUMBER FIVE WHAT KIND OF SKI HI
WIENER AYE WILK. HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. MCGUIRE
PORTANTINO THIS IS THIRTY SIX
NO ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED LIVING ON ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN. SENATOR HERTZBERG THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT
THIS IS RELATES TO THE
CONFIRMATION OF DOCTOR RICHARD
THORPE- TO THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL BOARD HE ALSO APPEARED
BEFORE US THAT THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON FEBRUARY THREE- DR
THORPE IS THE PRESIDENT AND
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF
PARADISE MEDICAL GROUP. HE IS
THE FORMER MEDICAL DIRECTOR OF
FEATHER RIVER HOSPITAL RURAL
HEALTH CLINICS AGAIN AS I SAY
HE WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE S. HERE. FIVE OH. IT
LOOKS SENATOR PENN THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT OF CENTERS I TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE
CONFIRMATION OF- RICHARD THORPE
AND THE- HE'S A HIGHLY
RESPECTED POSITION IN THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY I SHOULD MAKE
NOTE THAT- IT'S AS CHICO ON THE
SHEET BUT THAT'S BECAUSE HE
PRACTICED IN PARADISE FOR A
LONG TIME AND THEN HIS PRACTICE
AND THAT THE TOWN BURNED DOWN.
AND SO- SO CERTAINLY HE HIMSELF
KNOWS MANY OF THE ISSUES THAT-
PEOPLE THE COMMUNITY HAVE FACED
HE'S BEEN A LONG TIME. PERSONS
PROVIDED CARE ALL PEOPLE WHO
LIVE IN THIS COMMUNITY
CERTAINLY I THINK TO ME WOULD
BE AN EXCELLENT- PERSON TO
SERVE ON THE MEDICAL BOARD
CALIFORNIA AND I'D URGE AND I
DON'T THINK YOU. SENATOR
MELENDEZ. THINK NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION US SENATOR NIELSEN.
NOT A PRESERVATION GEM OF THE
SENATE I URGE A VERY VIGOROUS I
VOTE FOR THIS GENTLEMAN. I'VE
KNOWN HIM FOR MANY MANY YEARS
IS THAT A PROMINENT MAN AROUND
HIS COMMUNITY SERVING IN THAT
AREA. HE WAS IN THE ESTEEM OF
HIS PEERS. WHO PUT IN AS
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION. FOR A TERM.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN WHEN THE PARADISE
FIRE RANGE. AND BURNED HIS
CLINIC. AT HIS HOME. HE WAS
DELIVERING HEALTH CARE AND
RELIEF. THE CITIZENS OF THAT
BURNING CITY. WHILE HIS OWN
PROPERTY IT'S GOING UP IN
FLAMES. THE COURAGE AND
DEDICATION TO THE COMMUNITY CAN
BE NO GREATER. I FELT THEN WHEN
YOU IN YOUR HEART PUT YOUR LIFE
AT RISK. TO SAVE YOUR FELLOW
CITIZENS. AND RICHARD THORPE
HAS DONE THAT AS WLL AS
NOTABLY AND VERY ABLY SERVING
HIS PROFESSION I URGE AN AYE
VOTE FOR MISTER RICHARD THORPE
MD. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NINE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES FIVE BAKER
FIVE FORTUS FIVE BRADFORD FIVE
BY ADAM HI HIGH COURT TESTING.
I DALY FIVE DODD. HI THE RISER
FIVE EGGMAN I GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ HI GROSS. HI HERTZBERG
FIVE HUESO HI HER TADO. HI
JONES FIVE KAMLAGER I LAYERED I
LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ.
FIVE MEAN FIVE NEWMAN I NIELSEN.
FIVE HOTEL OF THE HI PAN HI
PORTANTINO. ROTH FIVE RUBIO.
FIVE SKINNER FIVE NUMBER FIVE
WHAT KIND OF SKI FIVE WIENER. I
WILK HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. MCGUIRE PORTANTINO.
FIVE THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT. SENATE
SENATOR HERTZBERG. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT THIS RELATES TO
THE CONFIRMATION OF DOCTOR DE
HAVE GOT NONE OF THEM OF FOR
THE APPOINTMENT TO THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD BUT TO
GET UNDER THOSE CHAIRS THE
DEPARTMENT OF SURGERY AT
ARROWHEAD REGIONAL MEDICAL
CENTER IN SAN BENITO COUNTY IS
ALSO A CLINICAL PROFESSOR
MEMBERS OF SURGERY AT WESTERN
UNIVERSITY OF HEALTH SCIENCES
AT LOW BELINDA UNIVERSITY HE
WAS APPROVED LIKE THE OTHERS
AFTER A LONG DISCUSSION THAT
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON
FEBRUARY THIRD. ASK YOUR RIVALS.
SENATE THANK YOU MA'AM PRESENCE-
I TO RUN IN SOME OF THE
CONFIRMATION OF DOCTOR DAVID AN
ADDITIVE. HE'S- AGAIN ANOTHER
HIGHLY RESPECTED POSITION IN
THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY HE- IN
ADDITION TO BEING- SOME OF WHOM
TO SERVE ON THE MEDICAL BOARD
ALREADY WITH THE STATION HE
ALSO- IS A LEADING SURGEON
HE'S- LET NONPROFIT EFFORTS TO
HELP THE PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN GANGS TO REMOVE
THEIR TATTOOS HE'S- ACTUALLY
HELPING FOUND MEDICAL SCHOOL IN
THE REGION. SO AGAIN ANOTHER
DISTINGUISHED PHYSICIAN WHO I
THINK WOULD SERVE WELL SERVE
THE MEDICAL BOARD ARE
CONTINUING TO SERVE THE MEDICAL
BOARD HIGHER TONIGHT THANK YOU.
SENATOR HER TADO. THANK YOU AYE
REYES TODAY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE RE APPOINTMENT OF DR DEATH
BUT NONE OF IF TO THE MEDICAL
BOARD THE MACHINE OF THE
MEDICAL BOARD IS TO PROTECT
HEALTH CARE CONSUMERS THROUGH
PROPER LICENSING AND REGULATION
OF PHYSICIANS AND SURGEONS AND
SURGEONS THROUGH OBJECTIVE
ENFORCEMENT OF THE MEDICAL
PRACTICE ACT AND TO PROMOTE
ACCESS TO QUALITY CARE TO ALL
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. THE
CARBON NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
HIGHLIGHTED EXISTING
DISPARITIES IN CARE BETWEEN
URBAN AND RURAL RESIDENTS OF
THE OF OUR STATE BUT THESE
DISPARITIES EXISTED LONG BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC BEGAN SOME OF THIS
IS DUE TO WHAT INCENTIVIZE
PHYSICIANS TO PRACTICE WHERE
THEY ULTIMATELY CHOOSE TO BUT
IN MY MIND IT IS DUE TO A LACK
OF STRONG OVERSIGHT BY THE
BOARD AND DISCIPLINARY
DECISIONS HEALTHCARE CONSUMERS
IN MY DISTRICT HAVE NOT
RECEIVED THE CARE THEY DESERVE
I AM CONCERNED THAT MEMBERS OF
THE BOARD HAVE NOT PROPERLY
MAINTAINED OBJECTIVELY AND
COULD DO BETTER NOT HOLDING THE
BOARD'S MISSION OF PROTECTING
PATIENTS. FOR THIS REASON I
CANNOT VOTE TO APPROVE DR TO
NON OF ITS APPOINTMENT. SENATE
ROTH. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
THINK IS MOST OF YOU ON THE
FLOOR NO WE HAD A RATHER
DIFFICULT TO SUNSET REVIEW
OVERSIGHT HEARING ON FRIDAY
LASTED FIVE HOURS ACTUALLY WITH
RESPECT TO THE MEDICAL BOARD
FURTHER WORSENING WHAT I WOULD
CALL INSTITUTIONAL OR SYSTEMIC
ISSUES THAT WERE IDENTIFIED
THAT REALLY REQUIRES SOME
FURTHER EXPLANATION HAVING TO
DO WITH. THE ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS THAT THE BOARD IMPLIES
TRANSPARENCY- PERHAPS OF SOME
OF THE DECISIONS AND MORE
PARTICULARLY THE RATIONALE FOR
THE DECISIONS- BUT I'M HERE TO
TELL YOU THAT THERE WAS NO
EVIDENCE AND NO TESTIMONY. OF
THE THAT WAS A DUES TO DURING
THE HEARING TO POINT ANY
MISCONDUCT ON THE PART OF ANY
BOARD MEMBERS. TO INDICATE ANY
ON FITNESS OR LACK OF
QUALIFICATIONS FOR SERVICE. I
FOR ONE KNOW HAVE KNOWN A- DR
DEV GENITIVE FOR MANY MANY MANY
YEARS. OF LIKE MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SACRAMENTO I'M CERTAINLY
WELL AWARE OF HIS MANY
CONTRIBUTIONS IN THE MEDICAL
COMMUNITY I'M PARTICULARLY
ACUTELY AWARE OF HIS
EXTRAORDINARY CONTRIBUTIONS IN
WHAT IS AN UNDER SERVED THERE
IN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS SAN
BERNADINO AND RIVERSIDE
COUNTIES. HIS ACTIVITIES AND IN
PERSONALLY LEADING THE EFFORT
TO FORM A NEW MEDICAL SCHOOL
DOWN IN SAMBAR TO DINO DINO
COUNTY ASSOCIATED WITH THEIR-
HAD REGIONAL MEDICAL CENTER HIS
MANY EFFORTS TO IMPROVE THE
HEALTH CARE OF THE VERY.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
WE SPEND MOST OF OUR TIME HERE.
WORRYING ABOUT IN TRYING TO
PROVIDE FOR. AGAIN I WOULD ALSO
POINT OUT THAT WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THESE BOARDS IN
PARTICULAR BOARD SUCH AS THE
MEDICAL BOARD. WE ASK
INDIVIDUALS PROFESSIONALS WE AS
PHYSICIANS PSYCHOLOGISTS.
LAWYERS REALTORS INDIVIDUALS
FROM VARIOUS WALKS OF LIFE WHO
TYPICALLY ARE VERY VERY.
SUCCESSFUL IN THEIR INDIVIDUAL
PRACTICES AND PROFESSIONS. TO
COME FORWARD TO ATTEND BOARD
MEETINGS. TO LISTEN THE
TO MAKE VERY VERY DIFFICULT
DECISIONS AS VOLUNTEERS FOR
WHICH WE COMPENSATE THEM AT THE
EXTRAORDINARY RATE OF ONE
HUNDRED DOLLARS A DAY. PER DIEM
AND I THINK WE NEED TO TAKE
THAT INTO CONSIDERATION AND AS
THEY DO THAT BY THE WAY. THEY
SUBJECT THEMSELVES OFTEN.
DECEMBER DIFFICULT
CONVERSATIONS AS WE HAD ON
FRIDAY WITH SOME OF THEM AND TO
SOME FAIRLY SIGNIFICANT ABUSE
THE SAME SORT OF ABUSE THAT WE
SOMETIMES FACE. AS ELECTED
OFFICIALS ARE DOING OF AN
ENTIRELY DIFFERENT JOB SO I'M
HERE TO STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE REAPPOINTMENT OF DR DEV
GENITIVE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL BOARD IN THAT REGION I
VOTE. SENATOR LEYVA. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I STANDAS
STRONG SUPPORTER ALSO DOCTOR
DEATH DEATH KENNEDY OF DR DEV
AS WE CALL HIM IN THE DISTRICT
I HAVE NEVER KNOWN HIM TO BE
SOMEONE OTHER THAN SOMEONE WHO
CARES ABOUT THE COMMUNITY ALSO
SEE MY COMMENTS WITH THE
SENATOR FROM RIVERSIDE COMMENTS
WORKED SO HARD TO BRING ANOTHER
MEDICAL SCHOOL TO THE INLAND
EMPIRE AND COLTON- WHICH WE
NEED DESPERATELY AND THIS IS
ALWAYS BEEN A MAN OF THE
COMMUNITY AND I'M THRILLED THAT
HE WILL BE HOPEFULLY RE
APPOINTED TODAY. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SAYING MAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS I
BASS FIVE BAKER. FIVE LARGEST.
BRADFORD I CUT BY OTHER I
CORTES THREE I DALY. DODD FIVE
TORONTO I EGGMAN FIVE GLAZER
FIVE GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH.
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. FIVE HER
TADO NO JONES. HI KAMLAGER HI-LAYERED I LIKE LEYVA. I REQUIRE.
MELENDEZ MAN FIVE NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. I CHIRLA BOTH I PAN
AYE PORTANTINO. ROTH FIVE RUBIO
HI SKINNER HI NUMBER HI BY
CASTING. HI WIENER. FIVE WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
TH REGIS. TALLY GROVE. I
MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ PORTANTINO.
WILK THIS. IS THIRTY ONE KNOWS
ONE. THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS- FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
DOCTOR PHIL ENTEI RIDDLE TO THE
BOARD OF JUVENILE HEARINGS HER
PROFESSIONAL BACKGROUND
INCLUDES A TWENTY EIGHT YEAR
CAREER WITH THE PASADENA POLICE
DEPARTMENT INCLUDING SERVING AS
THE DEPARTMENT'S FIRST EVER
BLACK FEMALE LIEUTENANT SHE HAS
ALSO TAUGHT CRIMINAL JUSTICE
CLASSES AS A COLLEGE PROFESSOR
SERVED AS LEGISLATIVE STAFF
ALONG WITH EXTENSIVE COMMUNITY
INVOLVEMENT. SHE WAS APPROVED
BY THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE
ON MARCH SEVENTEENTH ON A FIVE
ZERO VOTE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
APPOINTMENT. I THINK. SENATOR
BRADFORD Q. I JUST WANT TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF WANT TO READ-
SOMEONE I'VE KNOWN FOR ALMOST
TWENTY YEARS AND SHE SAID
CONSUMMATE PROFESSIONAL AS
STATED SPENT TWENTY NINE YEARS
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT A ROSE TO
THE RANK OF LIEUTENANT WHICH IS
A- EIGHT SIX ORDINARY FEATURES
pSPECIAL WOMAN OF COLOR ON SHE'S
ALSO SERVED AS DISTRICT
DIRECTOR FOR HUMAN HOLDEN AND
IS COMMITTED TO COMMUNITY
SERVICE SO I THINK SHOULD BE A
GREAT VOICE ON THIS JUVENILE
PROBATION BOARD. BRING
COMMONSENSE APPROACH TO MEETING
OUT JUSTICE AND REFORM FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE I HAVE STRUGGLED.
SENATOR LEYVA. THANK YOU IN
PERSON I DON'T USUALLY SPEAK ON
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS BUT
TODAY WERE TWO PEOPLE THAT I-FEEL QUITE NOTEWORTHY- DOCTOR
PHIL ONE T. A RIDDLE WHAT AN
AMAZING WOMAN- WHEN I MET HER
WHEN SHE WAS RUNNING FOR THE
SENATE I WAS INCREDIBLY
IMPRESSED BY HER SPIRIT HER
PASSION HER WORK ETHIC AND
EVERYTHING THAT THE GOOD
SENATOR SAID FROM- LA. SORRY OF-
SHE IS JUST SOMEONE WHO DOESN'T
GIVE UP AND WHEN SHE DID NOT-
GET ELECTED TO THE SENATE THAT
DID NOT STOP HER SHE FOUND
OTHER WAYS TO GET BACK TO HER
COMMUNITY. I CAN'T THINK OF
ANYONE BETTER FOR THIS PROPOSED
AT- DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE HEARINGS I THINK SHE'LL
DO AN AMAZING JOB. AND I HOPE
YOU ALL VOTE BY AS WELL. SEEING
NO FURTHER. COMMENT CENTER
BATES. ADD UP I'D BEEN INVOLVED
IN A NUMBER OF THE INTERVIEWS-
AS A NEW MEMBER OF THE RULES
AND I DID THIS INTERVIEW OF DR
RIDDLE WAS REALLY QUITE
AMAZING- SHE DID NOT HESITATE
ON ANY OF THE TOUGH QUESTIONS
THAT WERE POSED TO HER
REGARDING SOME OF THE THOUGH
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF
FEELINGS ABOUT SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT SHE'S DONE IT WAS
REALLY I THINK FOR ME ONE OF
THE BEST AND ONE OF THE MOST-
OPEN AND ARE TRANSPARENT AND
ACCOUNTABLE FOR HER PAST. AND
HER PRESENT AND WHAT SHE HOPES
TO DO IN THE FUTURE SO I HIGHLY
RECOMMEND AND I VOTE. SIGNAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
I BAKER. HI FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO HI
PROTESTING HI DALLY HI DODD.
FIVE TO RAZA FIVE EGGMAN I
GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ I GROWTH
FIVE HERTZBERG AYE HUESO. HI
FURTADO. FIVE JONES FIVE
KAMLAGER FIVE LAYERED I LEYVA
FIVE MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ FIVE
MILLION I NEWMAN FIVE NIELSEN.
BY A SHOW OF BOTH FIVE PAN HI
PORTANTINO. ROTH FIVE RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER. HI I'M BURKE I Y.
CASKEY HI WIENER AYE WILK. I
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MCGUIRE PORTANTINO. FIVE THIRTY
SIX NO ZERO. DEPARTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MEMBERS WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO THE SENATE THIRD
READING THE FIRST ITEM UP IS
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN SENATOR
LEYVA. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SEVENTEEN BY SENATOR
LEYVA RELATIVE TO RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION CENTER LEYVA THE
FLOOR'S YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SEVENTEEN RECOGNIZING MARCH
TWENTY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AS THE INTERNATIONAL DAY FOR
THE ELIMINATION OF RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION THE UNITED
NATIONS ALSO SERVES THAT DATE
WITH THE SIMILAR RECOGNITION
THE DAY IS OBSERVED ANNUALLY ON
THE DAY THE POLICE IN
SHARPEVILLE SOUTH AFRICA.
OPENED FIRE AND KILLED SIXTY
NINE PEOPLE AT A PEACEFUL
DEMONSTRATION AGAINST APARTHEID
IN NINETEEN SIXTY MEMBERS AS WE
ALL KNOW THE STRUGGLE AGAINST
RACISM AND RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION CONTINUES TO
THIS DAY. I WOULD HAVE HOPED
THAT IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE OVER
A HALF CENTURY AFTER MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR WAS
ASSASSINATED AMERICA WILL BE IN
A BETTER PLACE OF EQUALITY AND
UNDERSTANDING FOR ALL PEOPLE.
THE RECENT PROTESTS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND EVEN COME EVEN
COMMENTS AND ACTIONS FROM SOME
FEDERAL LEADERS IN RECENT YEARS
OR CLEAR REMINDER THAT RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION IN VARIOUS FORMS
IS A REALITY TO THIS DAY SO LET
US COME TOGETHER AS AMERICANS
AND LOVE AND TREAT ONE ANOTHER-WITH EVERY BIT OF RESPECT THAT
EVERY PERSON DESERVES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE
ON S. C. R. SEVENTEEN THANK
YOU. SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU
MADAM FOR- SENATOR I TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS YEAR. VESSEY
ARE SEVENTEEN- I THINK MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM CHINO FOR BRING
THIS FORWARD AS- PROUD TO
AUTHOR AND CHAIR OF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS. CERTAINLY HONOR TO
RECOGNIZE THE INTERNATIONAL DAY
FOR LIMITATION OF RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION. I POINT OUT
THAT- CERTAINLY WE HAVE OUR
CHALLENGES HERE BUT THIS IS-
MANY TIMES- THAT OUR COUNTRY IS
A LEADER AROUND THE WORLD
UNFORTUNATELY WE ALSO- WHAT
THERE WE ALSO FOUGHT SOME OUR
WE ALSO CAN BE IMPLICIT IN SOME
OF THE- SERVE RACIAL
STEREOTYPES- PEOPLE AROUND THE
WORLD FOR EXAMPLE I KNOW IN
SOUTH ASIA WE TALK ABOUT
WHITENING CREAMS- NOW SOME OF
THIS MADE AS A LEGACY OF
COLONIALISM OTHER TYPES OF
ACTIVITIES AS WELL BUT
CERTAINLY HERE EVEN HERE IN OUR
COUNTRY I SHOULD POINT OUT THAT
AND TWENTY NINETEEN I HELD AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING OF THE AS
CHAIR OF THE SENATE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON API FAIR STRAIGHT
WILL RAISE AWARENESS ON THE
MODEL MINORITY MYTHS AND THE
BEARS THAT ATI'S FACE. RE
REACHING LEADERSHIP ROLES IN
PROFESSIONAL WORKPLACE OFTEN
TIMES- THE PEOPLE LOOK AT ASIAN
AMERICANS IS BEING QUOTE THE-
ASIAN HAVING THE ASIAN
ADVANTAGE- BUT- FOR SOME OF OUR
SUB GROUPS BUT THESE ARE
RACIALIZED AND OVERSIMPLIFY
TREATMENTS STATEMENTS THAT MASK
THE COMPLEXITY DIVERSITY TO
EXISTING EACH RACIAL POPULATION
IN FACT ET I COMMUNITY IS NOT
HOMOGENEOUS IN FACT- DATA
DISAGGREGATION REVEALS ATKINS
THE SOBERING REALITY THAT EACH
GROUP HAS VARIOUS LEVELS OF
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT INCOME
AND IMMIGRATION HISTORY HOWEVER
BECAUSE OF THE MODEL MINORITY
MYTH THE API CAN USE OFTEN
FORGOTTEN IN MANY CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT RACE EDUCATION EQUITY
LEADERSHIP ADVANCEMENT HEALTH
DISPARITIES. FOR EXAMPLE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN A STUDY CO AUTHORED
BY CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE GOODWIN LIU SHOW THAT
ASIAN AMERICANS ARE MORE THAN
10% OF THE GRADUATES OF THE TOP
THIRTY LAW SCHOOLS SO THAT'S
THE PART ONE GOES NAY BUT YET
HAS THE HIGHEST ATTRITION RATES
IN THE LOWEST RACIAL PARTNERS
TO ASSOCIATES AMONG ALL RACIAL
GROUPS EFFECT OR UNDER
REPRESENTED IN THAT COURTS AND
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS AS FAR AS I CAN TELL
IN ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
WE DO NOT HAVE AN API DISTRICT
ATTORNEY. WHO IS- IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA EVEN AS WE'RE
FACING AT INCREASES AND HATE
AGAINST ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDERS
RESPECT HEALTH DISPARITIES
RECENT NEWS ARTICLES HAVE SHOWN
THAT COVERED NINETEEN HAS
IMPACTED THE PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITY SEVERELY IS THE RATE
AMONG NEEDLEPOINT PACIFIC
ISLANDER PRESENTS. THE SEGMENT
CAME LAST YEAR CAME TO FORT
PERCENT NEARLY TWICE SIZE. THE
AB OF. COUNTRY AVERAGE OF TWO
ONE FOR AND ACTUAL HIGHER THAN
OTHER RAY- SO SINCE THE START
OF A PANDEMIC OUR COMMUNION
ONLY FACED SEVERITIES CAUSED BY
SYSTEMIC RACISM BUT ALSO HAS
BEEN USED AS A SCAPEGOAT FOR
THE PANDEMIC. THE TO RISE SHARP
ANTI ASIAN VIOLENCE. THIS YEAR
SEVENTEEN COMES AT A CRITICAL
TIME REMINDERS THAT THE REAL
PLAGUE IN OUR SOCIETY IS
RACISM. THAT WE MUST COME
TOGETHER TO AND THIS IS A
PLAGUE THAT NOT ONLY THAT BUT
THE FACTS ARE CUT. COUNTRY AS
WELL AS AROUND THE WORLD I
STATE EXACTLY ASKING SUPPORT S.
C. R. SEVENTEEN THANK YOU.
SENATOR SKINNER. Q- MADAM
PRESIDENTMEMBERS I ALSO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS YEAR
SEVENTEEN- BOTH IN ON BEHALF OF
THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
BUT ALSO AS A- INDIVIDUAL AND I
APPRECIATE- OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
CHINO BRING THIS FORWARD I READ
OVER- OUR HOLIDAY BREAK THE
BOOK BY ISABEL WILKERSON CALLED
CAST AND EVEN EVEN THOUGH MANY
OF US WHO HAVE TRIED TO.
IMPROVE OUR EDUCATION IN TERMS
OF THE JUST POLICIES INST IN
OUR WHAT WE CALL IMPLICIT BIAS
VARIOUS THINGS WITHIN OUR
CULTURE OUR GOVERNMENT OUR
STRUCTURES IT'S I OPENING BOOKS
LIKE CAST TO LEARN FOR EXAMPLE
AND I'M SURE MANY ON THE FLOOR
PROBABLY KNEW THIS WELL BUT TO
LEARN FOR EXAMPLE THAT HITLER
AND THE **** USED THE US'S
RACIST RULES AND LAWS TO
PATTERN THEIR OWN- BASICALLY
THEIR OWN. OUR RULES AND OUR
PROGRAMS AGAINST JEWS GYPSIES
AND OTHERS FOUND OUT OF COURSE
IN SOUTH AFRICA APARTHEID TOOK
MUCH OF ITS IN- INSPIRATION OR
INSIGHT FROM OUR- HOW WE
TREATED OUR NATIVE AMERICANS
AND HOW WE CREATED-
RESERVATIONS- LAST NIGHT I
WATCHED SIXTY MINUTES. AND
THERE WAS A FASCINATING- EXPOSE
ON THE RACISM IN US MILITARY
AND THE NEW HEAD OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE- LLOYD
AUSTIN BIDEN'S APPOINTEE WAS AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN MAN AND A
GENERAL FROM THE AIRFORCE
TALKED ABOUT. HOW IN THEIR
FORTY YEARS IN THE MILITARY.
THE UNFORTUNATELY VERY LITTLE
HAS CHANGED AND THE GENERAL
FUND AIRFORCE DESCRIBED HOW
WHEN HE FIRST WHEN HE BECAME A
PILOT AIR FORCE PILOT. THERE
WERE 2% OF THE PILOTS THAT WERE
BLACK AND TODAY THERE ARE STILL
2% ONLY PILOTS IN THE AIR FORCE
WHO ARE BLACK- SO WE HAVE A
LONG WAY TO GO AND I BRING IT
UP EVEN THOUGH WE'RE THIS IS AN
INTERNATIONAL. A RESOLUTION
AROUND INTERNATIONAL RACISM
BECAUSE OF UNFORTUNATELY HOW SO
MANY OF OUR POLICIES OUR
COUNTRY'S POLICIES IN EFFECT.
INSPIRED OR WERE THE WERE THE
MODELTO PATTERN MANY OTHER
COUNTRIES VERY RACIST POLICIES
SO APPRECIATE THE RESOLUTION
AND I STAND IN SUPPORT. SENATOR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I TO
RISE- SECURED THE LEGISLATIVE
WHAT PARKER'S IN CALL AUTHORED
SCR SEVENTEEN OFFERING MY
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
AND I WANT TO RECOGNIZE AGAIN
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM CHINO FOR
BRINGING THIS FOR. BUT IN SOME
WAYS MEMBERS WERE HYPOCRITES.
WE'RE HYPOCRITES WHEN WE
ADVOCATE FOR INTERNATIONAL
ENDING A RACISM WHEN WE FAIL TO
ADDRESS IT RIGHT HERE IN OUR
OWN BACKYARD CALIFORNIA HAS AN
EXTENSIVE HISTORY OF RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION THE DATES BACK
TO THE FOUNDING. AND CONTINUES
TODAY TO BE TOLD AMERICA'S
PRIDE THE MOST RACIST COUNTRY
ON THE PLANET. RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION IS PART OF OUR
DNA. LET ME GIVE YOU SOME
EXAMPLES RAISING RACES OWNING
LAWS WERE USING SAN FRANCISCO
TO EXCLUDE CHINESE FAMILIES
FROM RESIDING IN CERTAIN PARTS
OF THE CITY. SINGLE FAMILY
ZONING WAS NEVER ABOUT HOUSING
CONFORMITY. IT WAS ABOUT RACIAL
EXCLUSION AND LACK OF DIVERSITY
IN NEIGHBORHOODS. ZOOT SUIT
RIOTS AND WHAT TRIED TO LOS
ANGELES WHERE THE RESULTS OF
BLATANT RACIAL DISCRIMINATION
AND SEGREGATION AGAINST LATINOS
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND OTHER
MINORITIES. MINORITIES IN ITS
STATE HAVE HAD TO RECKON WITH
THE CONSEQUENCES OF RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION FOR GENERATIONS.
WE SEE THOSE CONSEQUENCES AND
ARE OVER POLICING AND KILLING
OF BLACK AND BROWN INDIVIDUALS
ON A DAILY BASIS WE SEE IT IN
THE CANNABIS MARKET OR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES FACE
BARRIERS OF ENTRY DESPITE BEING
MOST HARMED BY THE WAR ON DRUGS
WE SEE IT IN THE WORKPLACE
WORST RACIAL DISCRIMINATION
LAWSUITS RUN RAMPANT. WE SEE IT
EVEN IN THIS BUILDING. WE SIT
IN OUR SCHOOLS WE SEE IT WITH
OUR YOUNG STUDENTS WHO ARE
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST CONTINUE
TO BE RACIALLY SEGREGATED. AND
ARE UNDER EDUCATED EVEN WHEN
THEY T. AND BETTER SCHOOLS AND
HAVE STATED WE SAID IN OUR
MILITARY. OR AFRICAN AMERICANS
MAKE UP ONLY 17% OF THE
MILITARY BUT 57% OF INVOLUNTARY
DISCHARGES TO THIS DAY. OF ALL
THESE CONSEQUENCES. BUT ALL
THESE CONSEQUENCES ONLY DOES.
BOOKSTORE ALL IT ONLY
EXACERBATED BY COVERT NINETEEN.
WE NOW KNOW THAT THE PEOPLE OF
COLOR WERE MORE LIKELY TO GET
COLD BUT MORE LIKELY TO SUFFER
SERIOUS SYMPTOMS AND MORE
LIKELY TO DIE OF COVERT. AND
LESS LIKELY TO HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE FOR VACCINES THIS
IS PRIORITIES DID NOT HAPPEN
OVERNIGHT. OR OVER THE PAST
YEAR BUT OVER CENTURIES OF
DISCRIMINATION AND LAW AND
POLICY. THERE IS MUCH WORK TO
BE NOT ONLY IN AT THE
STATE LEVEL BUT IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS BUSINESSES
SCHOOLS AS WELL AS OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND AROUND THE WORLD.
IT IS TIME. FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS IN THE NATION TO
STOP TALKING ABOUT RACIAL
EQUALITY AND START BEING ANTI
RACES PERMISSION AGREES. OUR
MISSION CREDIT. IT'S HARD IT'S
A HARD LIFE ON EASY STREET.
THIS WHITE IT FENCES BARS YOUR
I CAN SEE IF YOU THINK WE LIVE
IN THE LAND OF FREE. YOU TRY
BEING BLACK LIKE ME. ALL SUNDAY
WILL ALL BE FREE AND I'M PROUD
TO BE BLACK LIKE ME I'M PROUD
TO BE BLACK LIKE ME THOSE ARE
LYRICS FROM BLACK LIKE ME FROM.
MICKEY GUYTON A PHENOMENAL
COUNTRY SINGER PHENOMENAL
ARTIST IN AN OVER ALL RIGHT AND
SHE SPEAKS TO THE
DISCRIMINATION THAT SHE FACES.
TO THIS DAY EVEN THOUGH SHE
WANTED RAMIE LAST WEEK THE
DISCRIMINATION OF ANY COUNTRY.
S. RIVAL. SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
LEYVA YOU MAY CONCLUDE THANK
YOU BENEFIT PRESIDENT I DO
THINK ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THEIR POIGNANT COMMENTS AND I
AGREE IT'S TIME FOR EACH AND
EVERYONE OF US TO BE ANTI
RACIST I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
MY VOTE. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BECKER AYE FORGES AYE
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO HI
CORTESE AYE DALLY FIVE DODD
FIVE TO RAZA HI EGGMAN. I
GLAZER. FIVE GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
FIVE HERTZBERG AYE HUESO AYE
HER TADO FIVE JONES HI KAMLAGER
FIVE LAYERED I LEYVA FIVE
MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ FIVE MEN FIVE
NEWMAN. FIVE NIELSEN HI A TOTAL
OF BOTH I PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH. HI RUBIO I SKINNER.
HI NUMBER HI WHITE HOUSE SKI HI
WIENER FIVE WILK. HI. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MCGUIRE. I THIRTY SEVEN NO.
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
CENTER HERTZBERG FOR WHAT
PURPOSE DO RISE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH EMOTIONAL SOLUTIONS
RECONSIDERATION FILE NUMBER
EIGHT PLEASE. FILE NUMBER
EIGHT. RIGHT AT SCHOOL.
INTERXION CLEANER OKAY. THERE
IS A MOTION FOR RECONSIDERATION
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION. SINGMAN
EYES THIRTY SEVEN. NOTE ZERO.
RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
FIVE ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BATES
FIVE BAKER. FIVE FORGES.
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO HI
COURTESY I DALLY. DODD FIVE TO
RAZA. HI EGGMAN AYE GLAZER. HI
GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HER TADO.
NO JONES. KAMLAGER I LAYERED I
LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE. MELENDEZ
MAN FIVE NEWMAN I NIELSEN. A
TELEVOTE. PAN FIVE PORTANTINO.
FIVE ROTH FIVE RUBIO. I SKINNER.
HI I'M BURKE FIVE WHITE HOUSE
SKI HI WIENER AYE WILK. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. PORGES
DALLY. HUESO JONES. MCGUIRE
MELENDEZ. NIELSEN BUT CHAU BOTH.
FIVE WELL. HIS TWENTY EIGHT
KNOWS TO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. MEMBERS GOOD WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON IF YOU COULD JUST
GIVE ME A SECOND. MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE ONTO ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY CENTER EGGMAN. SHE IS
PREPARED PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION FOURTEEN BY SENATOR
EGGMAN RELATIVE TO SOCIAL WORK
MONTH SENATOR EGGMAN THE FLOOR
IS YOURS THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
GOOD AFTERNOON COLLEAGUES I
RISE 272% S. R. FOURTEEN
RECOGNIZING MARCH AS SOCIAL
WORK MONTH IN CALIFORNIA. EVERY
YEAR SINCE I'VE BEEN IN THE
LEGISLATURE I'VE BEEN A PART
OF- DECLARING MARCH IS SOCIAL
WORK MONTH WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF LAST YEAR OF COURSE AS WE
ENTERED INTO THE PANDEMIC- AT
WHICH TIME SOCIAL WORKERS OR
SOME OF THE ARE ESSENTIAL
PERSONNEL. YOU'LL FIND SUCH
WORKERS IN SCHOOLS AND
HOSPITALS AND PRISONS IN. IN
ANYWHERE THERE ARE PEOPLE FOR
THE MOST PART YOU'RE GONNA FIND
SOCIAL WORKERS THEY'RE TRYING
TO SHEPHERD THEM THROUGH- AND
HELPING PEOPLE THROUGH SOME OF
THE WORST TIMES. SO THIS YEAR
ESPECIALLY AS WE HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED WITH THE PANDEMIC- AND
WE'RE ALL MORE VULNERABLE NOW
AND MORE PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING
WITH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES IN
OUR IN OUR SCHOOLS ARE OUR
FIRST LINE RESPONDERS ARE
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS. AND
ALONGSIDE WITH THOSE FOLKS
OFFERING SUPPORT IN A IN THE
STRUGGLE. FOR SOCIAL WORKERS-
SO I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME IN
RECOGNIZING MARCH AS SOCIAL
WORK MONTHS ALSO WOMEN'S
HISTORY MONTH WHICH I LIKE TO
THINK THOSE TWO ARE CONNECTED
AS WE ARE A PROFESSION THAT-
OFTENTIMES IS OVER REPRESENTED
WITH WOMEN AND THE HELPING
PROFESSION- BUT JUST TO
RECOGNIZE PEOPLE FOR ALL THE
SACRIFICES THEY HAVE MADE TO
CONTINUE TO MAKE. IN DOING THIS
VERY DIFFICULT JOB AGAIN AS I
SAID ESPECIALLY NOW DURING THIS
TIME WITH THE INCREASE IN CHILD
ABUSE AN INCREASE IN ELDER
ABUSE- AND YOU CAN FIND SOCIAL
WORKERS ON THE FRONT LINES
THERE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. IS THERE ANY
DISK. OR ON THIS AND SENT PENN.
TEN SENATORS- I JUST WANNA
THANK MY GOOD FRIEND FOR
STOCKTON FOR BRING THE SPORT IS
A POSITION I KNOW HOW ESSENTIAL
SOCIAL WORKERS ARE WE TALK
ABOUT THE SOCIAL TERMS OF
HEALTH BUT- HOW DO WE ADDRESS
THOSE WELL WE CAN'T DO THAT
WITHOUT SOCIAL WORKERS WE
PROVIDE WE VOTE HERE AND WE-
FIND SERVICES FOR. PEOPLE IN
THE COMMUNITY AND HOW THE
PEOPLE FIND OUT ABOUT THE
SERVICE HOW TO GET THE SERVICES
OFTEN IT'S A SOCIAL WORKER
HELPS THEM GET THAT. AND ALSO
SOCIAL WORKERS PLAY A VERY
IMPORTANT ROLE PROVIDING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AS WELL SO WITH
THAT I TO URGE AN ITEMIZED
THANK MY GOOD FRIEND. STOCKTON
SPRINGS FOR. SAYING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CENTER
EGGMAN YOU MAY CONCLUDE. JUST
THINK YOU ARE EVERYBODY FOR
YOUR SUPPORT IN GOING FORWARD
AND- AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON PESAR FOURTEEN.
I'M SORRY IF YOU CONCLUDED
DEBATE I JUST WAS GOING TO CALL
THE SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND IS THE GRANDSON OF
A SOCIAL WORKER AND SOMEBODY
JUST BENEFITTED FROM SOCIAL
WORK IN HIS PAST WEEK FOR
PEOPLE WHO CAN'T ADVOCATE FOR
THEMSELVES- I HARDLY- SUPPORT
THIS RESOLUTION. THANKS THANKS
VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO THE USE OF THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SAYING
NINE ICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO.
THE RESOLUTION IS APPROVED
MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE. SENATOR
WESO IS PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE ELEVEN BY SENATOR
HUESO AN ACT RELATING TO HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES SENATOR WAIT SO
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I'M
PRESENTING SP THREE ELEVEN THE
COMPASSIONATE ACCESS TO MEDICAL
CANNABIS ACT OR ALSO KNOWN AS
RYAN'S LAW. THIS BILL IS NAMED
AFTER RYAN BARTEL A CALIFORNIA
NATIVE AND U. S. COAST GUARD
VETERAN WHO SADLY PASSED AWAY
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN AFTER A
BRIEF BUT VERY BRAVE BATTLE
WITH PANCREATIC CANCER. RYAN'S
LAW WOULD REQUIRE THAT
HOSPITALS AND CERTAIN TYPES OF
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES IN THE
STATE. ALLOW A TERMINALLY ILL
PATIENTS TO USE MEDICAL
CANNABIS FOR TREATMENT AND OR
PAIN RELEASED. LEAVE A
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN ALLOWING
THE USE OF MEDICAL MARIJUANA
NOW FOR MANY YEARS YET
SOMEBODY- SEEKING TO USE- OF
CANNABIS FOR MEDICAL TREATMENT
WITHIN A HOSPITAL IS CURRENTLY
NOT ALLOWED IN THAT DOES NOT
MAKE ANY SENSE ESPECIALLY AFTER
ALL THESE YEARS WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING THIS BILL VERY HARD
ALSO AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
KNOWING THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN.
CHANGES COMING AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL THAT ALSO MAKE THIS BILL.
A LOT MORE POSSIBLE IMPLEMENT-
AT THE STATE BUT WHETHER
WHETHER THAT HAPPENS OR NOT
THIS BILL INCLUDES A STRONG
SAFE HARBOR A CLAUSE THAT WOULD
ALLOW FACILITIES TO SUSPEND
COMPLIANCE SHOULD ANY FEDERAL
AGENCY INITIATED WERE FORSMAN
ACTION OR INDICATE ITS INTEREST.
IN ENFORCING FEDERAL CANNABIS
LAWS CURRENTLY THERE'S NO
BUDGET FOR ENFORCEMENT OF
CANNABIS LAWS- EVERY
ADMINISTRATION INCLUDE
COLLISION LAST AND THE CURRENT
ONE HAS LET THIS I LEFT THIS UP
TO STATES. WITH THIS
CONFIRMATION THE- OF COURSE
WITH THIS CLAUSE AND ALLOW US
TO PROTECT OUR STATE FACILITIES
ALSO WE'RE WORKING WITH CMS AT
THE STATE LEVEL ON THE
SAFEGUARDS TO MAKE SURE THAT-
WE WORK WITH THE HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES. IN OUR STATE TO
PROPERLY DRAFT THIS LANGUAGE UP
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY IS
COMFORTABLE WITH THIS BILL AND
WE'RE MAKING. PROGRESS BUT
LEAVES LEAVE SIMPLE LEAPS AND
BOUNDS WE'VE HAD PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS SO FAR WITH CAL
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
AND THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND WE WILL BE
MEETING EACH WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON THIS BILL
IT'S ABOUT TIME WE- ALLOW THIS
TO HAPPEN AND GIVE PEOPLE
ACCESS TO. CARE CARE THAT ALLOW
THEM TO BE- CONSCIENCE IN THERE
FROM THE FINAL DAYS OF THEIR
LIVES SO THANK YOU- MATTER
PRESENT MEMBERS AND I. WOULD
REALLY LIKE ALL OF YOUR SUPPORT
ON THIS BILL TODAY SO FAR THIS
IS BILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. SENATOR JONES. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
SB THREE ELEVEN BRIAN BARTELS
FATHER- JIM BARTEL WAS MY
PREDECESSOR ON THE SANTEE CITY
COUNCIL AND- WE HAVE HAD- SOME
VERY HEART WRENCHING AND
SERIOUS CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THIS ISSUE THIS IS A REASONABLE
EFFORT ADVERTISEMENT TERMINALLY
ILL PATIENTS AND I REGION II
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU. SIR ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SAYING NINE CENTER
HUESO YOU MAY CONCLUDE THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT THIS BILL
AND- I HOPE LIKE YOU CALLING ON
ALL YOUR SPORTS- TODAY TO MOVE
THIS FORWARD TO THE ASSEMBLY.
SENATORS ARE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO THE USE OF THE
ROLE.
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
THE USE OF THE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SAYING NINE FIVE THIRTY
SIX NO ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE CENTER
LEYVA IS PREPARED. IF YOU COULD
GIVE US. ONE SECOND PLEASE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY THREE.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETEEN BY SENATOR LEYVA
RELATIVE TO EQUAL PAY DAY.
CENTER LEYVA THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE AND I HAVE A
LOVE HATE RELATIONSHIP WITH
THIS RESOLUTION I LOVE THAT I
CAN RISE AND SPEAK ABOUT IT BUT
I HATE THAT IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WE'RE STILL TALKING ABOUT
J. EQUITY FOR WOMEN. SO I RISE
TO PRESENT SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION NINETEEN WHICH
PROCLAIMS WEDNESDAY MARCH
TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AS EQUAL PAY DAY IN RECOGNITION
OF THE NEED TO ELIMINATE THE
GENDER PAY GAP IN EARNINGS BY
WOMEN'S MARCH TWENTY FOURTH
MARKS HOW FAR INTO THE YEAR THE
NEXT YEAR WOMEN HAVE TO WORK TO
EARN AS MUCH AS THEIR MALE
COUNTERPARTS DID THE PRIOR
YEAR. IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WOMEN WORKING FULL TIME AND
YEAR ROUND ARE PAID EIGHTY TWO
CENTS FOR EVERY DOLLAR PAID TO
A MAN WHO WORKS FULL TIME AND
YEAR ROUND SADLY EQUAL PAY DAY
IS ONLY WORSE FOR WOMEN OF
COLOR. BLACK WOMEN EARNING
SIXTY THREE CENTS TO THE DOLLAR
MOST WORK UNTIL AUGUST THIRD.
AIRCON WOMEN EARNING SIXTY
CENTS ON THE DOLLAR MUST WORK
UNTIL SEPTEMBER EIGHT. AND
LATINA WOMEN EARNING FIFTY FIVE
CENTS TO THE DOLLAR MUST WORK
UNTIL OCTOBER TWENTY FIRST. TO
BE PAID WHAT A MAN WAS PAID THE
YEAR PRIOR. WELL EQUAL PAY DAY
FOR API WOMEN IS EARLIER IN THE
YEAR ON MARCH FIFTH THEY ALSO
SUFFER A NOTABLE PAY GAP. AAPI
WOMEN CAN EARN AS LITTLE AS
FIFTY TWO CENTS. AS BURMESE
WOMEN DUE TO EIGHTY FIVE CENTS
OVERALL FOR EVERY DOLLAR PAID
TO MEN. WE MUST ALSO RECOGNIZE
HOW THE PAY GENDER GAP HAS BEEN
FURTHER COMPOUNDED BY THE
OVERALL GREATER IMPACT OF
COVERED NINETEEN. THIS IS HAD
ON WOMEN AND PARTICULARLY WOMEN
OF COLOR. THE DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC ON WOMEN
WILL ALSO LIKELY HAVE A DIRECT
IMPACT ON ON GOING ON THE
ONGOING WAGE GAP IN CALIFORNIA.
IN THE NATION MEMBERS ON
AVERAGE WOMEN EMPLOYED FULL
TIME IN THE UNITED STATES WAS A
COMBINED TOTAL OF MORE THAN.
NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX
BILLION DOLLARS EVERY YEAR DUE
TO THE WAGE GAP THAT'S JUST AN
INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF MONEY.
THESE WERE LOST WAGES MEAN THAT
WOMEN IN THEIR FAMILIES HAVE
LESS MONEY TO SUPPORT
THEMSELVES SAVE AND INVEST FOR
THE FUTURE AND SPENT ON GOODS
AND SERVICES. THE GENDER GAP IS
A MEASURE OF JUST HOW FAR
NATION STILL HAS TO GO TO
ENSURE THAT WOMEN CAN
PARTICIPATE FULLY. AND EQUALLY
IN OUR ECONOMY MEMBERS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. CENTER RUBIO. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE I RISE
AS A PROUD CO AUTHOR TWO S. C.
R. NINETEEN I HAVE WTNESSED
THE STARK DISPARITIES BETWEEN
MEN AND WOMEN OF ALL IT TOOK TO
THE WORKPLACE AND WAGES IT IS
UNACCEPTABLE THAT IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WOMEN CONTINUE TO
FACE A GAP EARNINGS SIMPLY AND
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE OF THEIR
GENDER STUDIES SUGGEST THAT THE
PANDEMIC HAS WIDENED THIS GAP
AND HAS HIGHLIGHTED THE WOMEN'S
THAT WOMEN'S JOBS OR ONE POINT
EIGHT TIMES MORE VULNERABLE TO
AND THESE TYPE OF CRISES THAT
MEN'S JOBS. FURTHER WOMEN ARE
MORE VULNERABLE TO COVER
NINETEEN RELATED ECONOMIC A FAX
BECAUSE OF EXISTING GENDER
INEQUALITIES I WON'T GO INTO
THE DETAIL DISPARITIES AS A
GREAT SENATOR FROM HINO
HIGHLIGHTED EACH CATEGORY BUT
WHEN WOMEN ARE COMPENSATED.
PROPERLY WE ALL WIN IN
CALIFORNIA. GREATER GENDER
EQUALITY IS GOOD FOR THE STATE
IS GOOD FOR THE ECONOMY AND
IT'S GOOD FOR OUR SOCIETY AS A
WHOLE AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE THANK YOU. SENATOR PENN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS- I TOO WANT TO STAND
AS STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS YEAR
NINETEEN AND- THANK CENTER-
BECAUSE ENTER FROM CHINO FOR
BEING THIS FORD IS CHAIR OF THE
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS- BUT MAKE NOTE THAT THE
AVERAGE. API WOMAN HAS TO WORK
AN ADDITIONAL THREE MONTHS TO
MAKE SAME PAYS WHAT WHITE MEN
EARNED A TWENTY TWENTY. BECAUSE
API WOMEN ARE TYPICALLY TAKE
PAID JUST 85% CENTS PER DOLLAR
IS I THINK IT WAS MENTIONED BY
THE AUTHOR. BUT THIS IS NOT THE
FULL STORY AND IN FACT- THIS
AGAIN HIGHLIGHTS THE IMPORTANCE
OF THIS AGGREGATING THE DATA
AND ALSO THE MODEL MINORITY
MYTH BECAUSE- OUR COMMUTES ARE
DIVERSE AND EACH API COMMUNITY
IS AFFECTED DIFFERENTLY. IT
MEANS WOMEN EARN AN AVERAGE OF
SIXTY SEVEN CENTS FOR EVERY
DOLLAR PAID TO WHITE NON
HISPANIC MALE HAWAIIAN LAOTIAN
WOMEN EARN AN AVERAGE OF SIXTY
TWO DAYS AND SIXTY ONE CENTS
CAMBODIAN MOM SAMOAN AND TONGAN
WOMEN EARN AN AVERAGE OF SIXTY
CENTS. THE PARTY WOMEN EARN AN
AVERAGE OF FIFTY FOUR CENTS AND
pWOMEN EARN AN AVERAGE OF FIFTY
TWO CENTS PER DOLLAR. THAT A
NON HISPANIC WHITE MALE EARNS
THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE AND I
THINK IT IS- ALSO MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM CHINO SAID IT'S A
SERVICE. WHEN THIS RESOLUTION
COMES UP- WE BTH NEED TO BRING
IT OUT AND ALSO WHICH WE DIDN'T
HAVE TO. BECAUSE A FORTUNE
MEANS THE PROBLEM STILL
CONTINUES TO EXIST- I
RESPECTFULLY ASKS FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION THE
HOPES THAT SOME DAY. WE WILL NO
LONGER NEED TO DO THIS
RESOLUTION AND THAT ALL WOMEN.
ARE NO MATTER WHAT THEIR A
RACER NEXT BUSINESS CITY HAVE-
EQUAL PAY TO- ALL MEN.
INCLUDING QUITE NOW HISPANIC.
YEAH THANK YOU. SENATOR RAZA.
THANK OU MADAM CHAIR AND I TO
THANK THE AUTHOR OUR SENATOR
FROM CHINO FOR RAISING THE
ISSUE OF GENDER GAP IN OUR
EARNINGS BY WOMEN AND AS SHE
SAID FOR LATINAS EQUAL PAY DAY
DOESN'T COME UNTIL OCTOBER
TWENTY FIRST. I DON'T KNOW WHAT
WE DO ON THAT DAY WE CELEBRATE
OUR WE CRY I AM NOT QUITE SURE.
BUT THE COVER NINETEEN HAD THAT
MAKE HAS BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY FELT BY. OUR
COMMUNITIES LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. THE HARDEST HIT
LATINOS ARE HEAVILY REPRESENTED
IN THE INDUSTRIES IMPACTED BY
COLBERT NINETEEN. MAKES A MORE
VULNERABLE JOB LOSS WAGE THEFT
AND INEQUITIES IN PAY SO IT
ISN'T JUST A- YOU KNOW. OUR
LADY HOW MUCH DO YOU GET HOW
MUCH DOES OFMALE COUNTERPART
GET IT'S ACTUALLY INSTITUTIONS
WITH THE SYSTEMS. LATINOS ARE
ALSO LESS LIKELY THAN OTHER
DEMOGRAPHIC GROUPS TAB PAID
SICK DAYS. THE OPTION OF
WORKING FROM HOME. MAKES THEM
MORE SUSCEPTIBLE CONTENT TO
CONTRACTING THE VIRUS AT WORK
AND MORE DIFFICULT TO MAINTAIN.
ECONOMIC AND HEALTH SECURITY.
LATINOS HAVE HAD LOWER PREPEND
THAT MAKE WAGES INCOME WEALTH
AND ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE- AND
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON
OBVIOUSLY FOR DECADES OF HAVING
BEEN OVER UNDERPAID AND
OVERLOOKED. I WOULD URGE MY
COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT OUR
UNSEEN LATINOS INITIATIVE TO
ENSURE THE LATINO WOMEN ARE
PART OF AN EQUITABLE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY WE SHOULD NEVER AGAIN
HAVE TO OBSERVE THE INJUSTICE
OF AN EQUAL PAY DAY OR LATINA
EQUAL PAY DAY THANK YOU.
SENATOR WIENER. THANK YOU IN A
PRESIDENT I RISE AS OUR VICE
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF YEAR NINETEEN OUR
INABILITY TO PAY WOMEN AT THE
SAME RATE AS THEIR MALE
COUNTERPARTS REPRESENTS A
CONTINUED MORAL FAILURE OF OUR
SOCIETY OUR JEWISH TRADITION
RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANCE OF
FAIR WAGES ARE WRITTEN
THOUSANDS OF YEARS AGO THE
TORAH COMMANDS US QUOTE YOU
SHALL NOT DEFRAUD YOUR NEIGHBOR
YOU SHALL NOT COMMIT ROBBRY
THE WAGES OF THE LABORERS ARE
NOT REMAIN WITH YOU UNTIL
MORNING AND QUOTE. ANOTHER
CENTRAL JEWISH TEXTS THE TALMUD
GOES EVEN FURTHER SAYING QUOTE
ONE WHO UPHOLDS THE WAGES OF A
HIRED LABOR IT IS THOUGH THEY
TAKE THEIR SOUL FROM THEM AND
QUOTE UNFORTUNATELY DESPITE
CLEAR ORDERS FROM OUR TRADITION
THE JEWISH COMMUNITY IS NOT
IMMUNE TO GENDER DISPARITIES
THAT AMERICAN JEWISH
INSTITUTIONS THE GENDER PAY GAP
IS ABOUT THE SAME AS THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE. ON THE TWENTY
NINTH HIGHEST PAID JEWISH
PROFESSIONALS ARE ALL MEN AND
AS EVIDENCED BY THE MAKE UP OF
OUR OWN LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS WE STILL HAVE MUCH WORK
TO DO TO UPLIFT JEWISH WOMEN
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY AND BEYOND
IN RECENT YEARS POSITIVE
PROGRAMS LIKE THE REFORM
MOVEMENT'S PAY EQUITY
INITIATIVE HAVE SERVICE TO
ADDRESS AND TACKLE THE GENDER
WAGE GAP FOR PROFESSIONALS WHO
SERVE AND THEIR INSTITUTIONS.
BUT WE STILL HAVE MUCH WORK TO
DO TO ACTUALLY ACHIEVE GENDER
EQUITY INSTEAD OF JUST STUDYING
AT- AND TO RID OUR SOCIETY OF
SYSTEMIC GENDER DISCRIMINATION
WE MUST TACKLE THIS ISSUE AT A
STRUCTURAL LEVEL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I WILL.
SENATOR CAMEL. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS I RIDE RIDES IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR S. C. R. NINETEEN
RELATIVE TO EQUAL PAY DAY YOU
KNOW W ALL KNOW THAT WOMEN
DON'T GET PAID THEY'RE WORTH
AND IF YOU DON'T KNOW THAT BY
NOW JUST ASK A WOMAN AND SHE
WILL TELL YOU. OVER FIFTY YEARS
AFTER THE PASSAGE OF THE
FEDERAL EQUAL PAY ACT OF ALL
WOMEN ESPECIALLY MINORITY
WOMEN. CONTINUE TO RECEIVE ON
EQUAL PAY. FOR DECADES BLACK
WOMEN HAVE CREATED SIGNIFICANT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES THROUGH EDUCATION
ENTREPRENEURSHIP POLITICAL
PARTICIPATION. AND IMPROVING
OUR ECONOMY AND SOCIETY. I
WOULD VENTURE TO SAY THAT BLACK
WOMEN ARE THE ULTIMATE.
HUSTLERS WHEN IT COMES TO
HUSTLING FOR CHILD CARE SHELTER
SAFETY EMPLOYMENT EDUCATION FOR
OUR BABIES AND DIGNITY AND WE
ARE STILL TRYING TO FIND SOME
EQUITY. IT TAKES THE TYPICAL
BLACK WOMAN NINETEEN MONTHS TO
BE PAID WHAT THE AVERAGE WHITE
MAN TAKES HOME IN TWELVE.
PARENTAL STATUS CAN ALSO HAVE A
GREAT IMPACT ON THE WAGE GAP
BLACK MOTHERS MAKE FIFTY CENTS
TO EVERY DOLLAR A WHITE FATHER
MAKES. AND I BET WE ARE DOING
TWICE AS MUCH WORK. THIS ISSUE
HAS ONLY GOTTEN WORSE WITH THE
INCREASING RESPONSIBILITIES
WOMEN HAVE HAD TO DEAL WITH
CARING FOR THEIR HOUSEHOLDS
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC. THE WELLBEING OF
BLACK WOMEN IS CRITICAL TO
THEIR FAMILIES TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND TO OUR COUNTRY
AS A WHOLE WE MUST ALL CONTINUE
TO RAISE AWARENESS ON THE ISSUE
OF PAY EQUITY FOR WOME. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. SENATOR BAKER. THE
SUPPORT OF S. C. R. NINETEEN R.
TWENTY TO ADD AS OUR VERY OWN
FORMER CENTER KAMEL HARRIS NO
VICE PRESIDENT SAID DURING HER
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN WE NEED
TO CHANGE THE BURDEN OF PROOF
FROM WOMEN TO HAVING PROVED
THAT PAYS MONEY GO TO COMPANIES
TO PROVE THAT THEY ARE PAYING.
EQUALLY ONCE WE DO THAT WE'LL
BE ABLE ON OUR WAY TO NOT
HAVING TO CELEBRATE EQUAL PAY
DAY AGAIN IN THE FUTURE THANKS.
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SENATOR LEYVA WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CONCLUDE THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU
MEMBERS FOR ALL OF YOUR
COMMENTS AND MUCH APPRECIATED I
JUST ASK YOU TO IMAGINE HOW
MANY WOMEN WOULDN'T STAY IN
ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIPS IF THEY
HAD EQUAL PAY SO MANY WOMEN
STAND THOSE RELATIONSHIPS
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT SUPPORT
THEMSELVES IMAGINE IN A TWO
PARENT HOUSEHOLD IF BOTH
PARENTS WERE PAID EQUALLY HOW
MUCH BETTER OFF THOSE CHILDREN
WOULD BE BUT I BRING YOU HOPE
TODAY. AS WE ALL SIT HERE IS
LEGISLATORS WE HAVE THE ABILITY
TO LEGISLATE IF COMPANIES WON'T
DO THE RIGHT THING CORPORATIONS
WON'T DO THE RIGHT THING WE CAN
DO THE RIGHT THING I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE VOTE.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO THE
USE OF THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SAYING NINE FIVE THIRTY FIVE NO
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WERE MCKENNA MOVED ON
TO ITEM NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT.
SENATOR JONES HE IS PREPARED.
IF YOU COULD GIVE US JUST A
SECOND. M. SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE RESOLUTION
EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR JONES
RELATIVE TO NATIONAL SURVEYORS
WEEK. SENATOR JONES A FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS SENATE- SENATE
RESOLUTION EIGHTEEN RECOGNIZES
THE WEEK OF MARCH TWENTY FIRST
THROUGH THE TWENTY SEVENTH IS
NATIONAL SURVEYORS WEEK. LAND
SURVEYING HAS A PROUD HISTORY
IN THE UNITED STATES IN FACT
SOME OF THE GREATEST AMERICANS
HAVE PERFORMED WORK I WORK AS A
LAND SURVEYOR SUCH AS GEORGE
WASHINGTON AND ABRAHAM LINCOLN
AND EVEN HENRY DAVID THOREAU.
THE WORK LANCET SURVEYORS DO IS
ESSENTIAL TO OUR SOCIETY. FROM
CONSTRUCTING INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS TO DETERMINE
GEOGRAPHICAL BOUNDARIES TO
RESOLVING DISPUTES OVER LAND
OWNERSHIP. MADAM PRESIDENT I'D
ASK FOR THE BODY TO PLEASE VOTE
AYE ON SR EIGHTEEN. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING THEN THIS
ITEM IS ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR YOU
THE UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ANY
OBJECTION TO THE USE OF THAT.
SEEING NONE I THIRTY FIVE NO
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MOVING ON TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ITEMS THIRTY SEVEN
THROUGH FORTY FOUR MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ACTUALLY
LET ME ASK FIRST ARE THERE ANY
OBJECTION OBJECTIONS OR
ANYTHING FROM THE CONSENT THAT
NEEDS TO BE PULLED. SINGMAN
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL. SEVENTY ONE FOUR
NINETY FOUR THREE TWENTY NINE
FOR THIRTY SIX FOR FIFTY EIGHT
EIGHT TEN EIGHT ELEVEN AND
SENATE BILL EIGHT TWELFTH MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM NUMBER. THIRTY SEVEN.
ALLEN. FIVE ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
AYE BATES. BAKER HI PORGES.
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO FIVE
CORTESE FIVE DALLY HI DODD. HI
THE RAZA. FIVE EGGMAN HI GLAZER.
FIVE GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH HI
HERTZBERG. HI HUESO HI HER TADO
FIVE JONES. FIVE KAMLAGER.
KAMLAGER FIVE LAYERED I LEYVA.
HI WIRE. MELENDEZ FIVE MILLION
I NEWMAN HI NIELSEN HI A TOTAL
OF BOTH. HI CAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO. FIVE
SKINNER FIVE UMBERG HI MY
CASKEY FIVE WIENER. HI WILK HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BATES HI PORGES FIVE. MCGUIRE.
IS THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO ON THE
ITEM I THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
ZERO ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
MOVING ON TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS SENATOR CORTESE.
GIVEN THE PRESIDENT DELIVER
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE- WILL MEET
UPON ADJOURNMENT OF THE SESSION
THANK YOU IN RUMORED FORTY TWO
OR THREE FOUR TWO THREE THANK
YOU. VERY GOOD. RETURNING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS MEMBERS
THIS IS THE TIME THAT WE WILL
ADDRESS THE ADJOURN IN MEMORY.
ITEMS WE'RE GONNA START WITH
SENATOR ARCHULETA. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY
THE GERMAN OF MEMORY OF DR MARY
SELL FOR BREAKFAST ALL FOR. THE
RIPE OLD AGE OF A HUNDRED THREE
YEARS OLD IMAGINE A HUNDRED AND
THREE. HE WAS KNOWN FOR HER
GENEROSITY ALWAYS LOOKING FOR
THOSE IN NEED IN THE COMMUNITY
IN PARTICULAR THOSE STUDENTS IN
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT. DR STYLE
FOR CREATED A FOUNDATION FOR
NEARLY NEARLY THIRTY YEARS
DONATED MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
THE COMMUNITY MOSTLY TO THE
CITY STUDENTS AND THE COMMUNITY.
DR STAUFFER GRADUATED FROM THE
OHIO STATE COLLEGE OF MEDICINE
IN NINETEEN FORTY THREE AND
MARRIED HER HUSBAND FLOYD AT
THE SAME YEAR. THE COUPLE LIVED
IN MY DISTRICT FIRST IN
MONTEBELLO BEFORE SETTLING IN
THE CITY OF DOWNEY. SHE
PRACTICED IN MY DISTRICT FIRST
THE MONTEBELLO BEFORE AS I SAID
IN THE CITY OF DOWNEY. HE
PRACTICED MEDICINE AT THREE
DIFFERENT LOCATIONS IN THE CITY.
UNDER HER RETIREMENT SHE ALWAYS
SOUGHT OUT THE BEST SERVICE AND
COMMITMENT TO THE COMMUNITY AND
SHE CONTINUED HER PROFESSION TO
THE RIPE OLD AGE OF EIGHTY.
WHEN SHE RETIRED. DR SULFUR WAS
A FOUNDING MEMBER OF GANGS OUT
OF DOWNEY AND JOIN THE DOWNEY
SISTER CITIES ASSOCIATION AND
THE CHRISTIAN BUSINESS WOMEN'S
ASSOCIATION WHICH SHE DONATED
COUNTLESS OF HOURS EACH AND
EVERY WEEK. DR MEREDITH
SHELFORD FOUNDATION AWARDED
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
SCHOLARSHIPS TO FIFTY
GRADUATING STUDENTS FROM DOWNEY
AND WORN HIGH SCHOOLS EVERY
SINGLE YEAR PUSH YEARLY
MONETARY AWARDS FOR UP TO EIGHT
HUNDRED STUDENTS PER YEAR. DR
SULFUR WILL BE TRULY MISSED BY
HER FAMILY AND FRIENDS
THROUGHOUT THE DISTRICT FOR
THESE REASONS I AFTER A GERMAN
OR MEMORY. SENATOR PLEASE BRING
HER NAME TO THE DESK SO THAT
SHE MAY BE APPROPRIATELY MEMBER
MEMORIALIZED BY THE SENATE.
SENATOR PORTANTINO. THANK YOU-
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE TO JR IN THE STATE SENATE
IN MEMORY OF REVEREND CANON DR
DR GEORGE REGUS COLLEAGUES
REFERENCE PREVIOUS PASSED AWAY
AT THE AGE OF NINETY ON JANUARY
THIRD TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
HE WAS ORDAINED A DEACON IN THE
EPISCOPAL CHURCH IN NINETEEN
FIFTY SIX AND THE PRIESTHOOD IN
NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN HE
SUCCEEDED JOHN BURKE AS RECTOR
WHEN HE WAS JUST THIRTY SIX
YEARS OLD. REVAN REGUS IS BOLD
LEADERSHIP ADVANCE CIVIL RIGHTS
WOMEN'S ORDINATING ORDINATION
LGBT MARRIAGE EQUALITY AND-REVERSING THE ARMS RACE AS
RECTOR IN PASADENA FROM.
NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN TO
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE DURING HIS
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS AT ALL
SAINTS HE FOCUSED ON PEACE AND
JUSTICE WHILE ALSO FORGING A
STRONG COMMUNITY OF FAITH FROM
A VERY VERY DIVERSE
CONGREGATION. EVAN REGUS WORKED
WITH HIS FRIEND ARCHBISHOP
ARCHBISHOP DESMOND TUTU TO
ESTABLISH A SOUTH AFRICAN
MINISTRY AT ALL SAINTS THE
FOCUS WAS TWO FOLD FIRST AN
EXCHANGE PROGRAM WITH SOUTH
AFRICAN CLERGY COMING TO
PASADENA FOR REST RENEWAL AND
MUTUAL ENRICHMENT AND
ORGANIZING A DELEGATION FROM
ALL SAINTS TO TRAVEL TO SOUTH
OF SOUTH AFRICA. THE CENTER WAS
ALSO AN ORGANIZING PLACE FOR
BOYCOTTING AND IN DEBT AND
INVESTMENT FROM SOUTH AFRICA
DURING REDUCES TENURE AT ALL
SAINTS THE CHURCH STARTED UNION
STATION IN NINETEEN SEVENTY AS-A COMPLETE WRAPAROUND SERVICE
CENTER FOR HOMELESS CITIZENS OF
SAY OF THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY
FOLLOWING THE SEPTEMBER
ELEVENTH TWO THOUSAND ONE
TERRORIST ATTACK IN NEW YORK
AND WASHINGTON DC REVAN REGUS
ESTABLISH THE INTERFAITH GROUP
COMMUNITIES UNITED FOR PEACE
AND JUSTICE. THE GROUP HAS
PLAYED A SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA'S
ADVOCATING FOR PEACE AND
SEEKING TO BE AN ALTERNATIVE
VOICE TO THE WAR ON TERRORISM
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX REGUS
ESTABLISHED. THE ALL SAINTS
AIDS SERVICE CENTER-
INTERVENTION BECAME A MAJOR
PROGRAM IN THE SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY. HE ALSO SUPERVISED THE
CREATION OF YOUNG AND HEALTHY
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR A
PIONEERING PROGRAM TO SERVE
UNINSURED AND UNDERINSURED
CHILDREN IN PASADENA. THIS
EFFORT HAS BECOME EXTREMELY
SUCCESSFUL HAS BEEN COPIED IN
SEVERAL OTHER CITIES. AFTER THE
BRUTAL HALLOWEEN MYRTLES WITH
MURDERS IN NINETEEN NINETY
THREE THAT LEFT FOUR TEENAGERS
DEAD AND FORCED THE CITY TO
ACKNOWLEDGE ITS GANG PROBLEMS
REGUS FOUNDED THE COALITION FOR
NONVIOLENT CITY WITH FORMER PCC
PRESIDENT. AND ARE SENATE
COLLEAGUE SENATOR JACK SCOTT.
BREVIN REDUCES SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE MARY LOW RE MCCASLIN WE
MARRIED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN HIS DAUGHTER SUSAN REGUS
HIS SONS TIM AND TYLER. MARY
SUNDBERG SMITH AND PLENTY
PLENTY OF FRIENDS FAMILY AND
CONGREGANTS TO MOURN WITH US
TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PLEASE BRING THE REVERENCE NAME
TO THE DESK SO THAT HE MAY BE A
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED BY
THE SENATE. SENATOR WIENER. I
THANK YOU MADAM PRESDENT-
COLLEAGUES IT'S WITH GREAT
SADNESS THAT I RISE TO ASK THAT
THE SENATE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY
OF SAMMY TO SEE SO ON A HIGHLY
VALUED MEMBER OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO COMMUNITY AND ALSO
THE CASTRO COMMUNITY ON MY HOME
OF TWENTY FOUR YEARS ASSEMBLY
TRULY EMBODIED THE AMERICAN
DREAM IMMIGRATED TO SAN
FRANCISCO FROM PALESTINE TO
OPEN A SMALL BUSINESS I FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO. DURING HIS TIME IN
SAN FRANCISCO ASSEMBLY OPEN
MULTIPLE CONVENIENCE STORES-
WITH- THE NO WE HELD MARKET AND
THE CASTRO NEIGHBORHOOD JUST A
FEW BLOCKS FROM WHERE I LIVE-
BEING HIS PRIDE AND JOY SAMMUT
WAS ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO
ALWAYS SEEM TO BE AROUND- WITH
A SMILING FACE AND A DEEPLY
INTIMATE CONNECTION. WITH HIS
COMMUNITY AND WITH OUR CASTRO
BY NEIGHBORHOOD HE ALWAYS
THOUGHT ABOUT OTHERS WHO TOOK OPPORTUNITY- JUST TO BE
CLIENTS TO PEOPLE HE KNEW WHO
THE NEIGHBORS WORKING PEOPLE'S
NAMES YOU KNEW THEIR KIDS- HE
KNEW PEOPLE'S PONE NUMBERS HE
WAS HAPPY TO RECEIVE PACKAGES-
FOR NEIGHBORS- HE WAS JUST THE
TYPE OF PERSON WHO WOULD GO
ABOVE AND BEYOND- BEER GROCERY
STORE OWNER HE WAS A TRULY A
GOOD NEIGHBOR THE KIND OF
PERSON WHO WOULD CALL YOU IF
YOUR CAR WAS ABOUT TO BE. TOWED
BY THE PEOPLE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD TRUSTED SAMMY- SO
MUCH SO THEY WOULD LEAVE HIM
SPARE KEYS- TO THEIR HOMES JUST
IN CASE I GOT LOCKED OUT. I WAS
KNOWN GET FREE POPS A- OR ICE
CREAM CONES TO. NEIGHBORHOOD
KIDS. AND TREATS TO DOGS THAT
WERE PASSING BY. HE DEDICATED
HIMSELF TO THE SMALL ACTS OF
KINDNESS. BY AND AFTER FIVE
AFTER MORE THAN A DECADE OF
SPREADING JOY AND GENEROSITY I
CAN SAY WITH CONFIDENCE THAT HE
HOLDS. A VERY SPECIAL AND A
PERMANENT PLACE IN THE HEARTS
OF THE PEOPLE OF OUR CANCER
COMMUNITY. ASSEMBLY PASSED AWAY
ON MARCH SEVENTH- FROM THE
CORONAVIRUS ONE OF. SO AS A NON
THINKABLE NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN
OUR STATE AND OUR COUNTRY IN
THIS WORLD. WHO ARE NO LONGER
WITH US BECAUSE OF THIS
HORRIFIC. PANDEMIC HE WAS A
FRONTLINE WORKER AND EVERY
SENSE OF THE WORD WHO WENT TO
WORK AND HE KEPT HIS STORE OPEN
KNOWING THAT PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY- WE'RE GOING TO NEED
FOOD. HE KNEW THAT IT WAS
ESSENTIAL TO KEEP THE GROCERY
STORE OPEN AND TO BE THERE FOR
THE COMMUNITY. AND HE PAID THE
PRICE WITH HIS LIFE. I SAMIT'S
SURVIVES- BY HIS WIFE HIS
DAUGHTER AND TWO SONS WE WILL
CONTINUE TO RUN- THIS IS
ESSENTIAL CRITICAL BUSINESS IN
OUR NEIGHBORHOOD. BUT PLEASE
JOIN ME TODAY. I IN RETURNING
THE SENATE AND MEMORY OF SAMMY
THE SEA SO. PLEASE BRING HIS
NAME FORWARD TO THE DESK SO
THAT HE MAY BE APPROPRIATELY
MEMORIALIZED BY THE SENATE.
THERE'S NO OTHER BUSINESS
CENTER ATKINS TO DISCUSS CLEAR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES ARE NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR THIS
THURSDAY MARCH TWENTY FIFTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT NINE AM
THANK YOU. THE SENATE WILL BE
IN RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY AT
WHICH TIME THE ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE WE WILL
RECONVENE THIS THURSDAY AT NINE
AM.